t merci monsieur le premier ministre la
palette à monsieur alain marsaud
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre il y un peu plus d'un
an de cela je vous avez interrogé sur le
financement du voyage djihadistes de la
soeur du terroriste merad toulouse et ce
par les allocations familiales seul
avait d'ailleurs provoqué l'ire de votre
ministre de l'intérieur et des membres
de votre majorité hélas ça n'a pu
constater combien cette préoccupation
était fondée puisque il est apparu que
le nombre de djihadistes présent
aujourd'hui sur le théâtre syriens
irakiens ont continué à percevoir les
allocations de toute nature c'est ainsi
qu'il a fallu faire intervenir à des
séries pas n'importe qui pour coopérer
avec les caisses d'allocations
familiales dans le but de faire cesser
ces abus mais il ya encore mieux figurer
vous avec le cas du radical islamiste
farouk banna baisse non français tuniso
d'unizo buts belges ou belgo-tunisien
domicile et à toulouse après quelques
mois de prison et qui perçoit depuis
cinq ans cinq ans le rsa c'est dire s'il
cherche du travail pire le ministère de
la justice lui a récemment attribué
semble-t-il par erreur pour riner
d'incarcération 21000 euros cela veut
dire que cet individu correspondant en
france des frères klein lesquels ont
revendiqué les attentats du 13 novembre
pour le compte de l'état islamique aura
perçu 54 mille euros d'argent public
pouvez vous nous donner aujourd'hui
monsieur le premier ministre en assurant
ce que ces versements vont cesser adapté
de ce jour et que vous en donnerai
toutes mesures nécessaires en ce sens
alors certains par facilité sans doute
après avoir entendu cette question
manifesteront leur incompréhension à
l'égard de ses propos mais mes chers
collègues les dames et messieurs les
ministres monsieur le premier ministre
nos compatriotes nous regardent et
mérite de comprendre comment une
situation aussi scandaleuse peut exister
aujourd'hui
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame ségolène neuville
secrétaire d'état chargé des personnes
handicapées et de la lutte contre
l'exclusion merci monsieur prévost vous
connaissez je les défie de connaissez la
manière dont bon nombre alors marc sauvé
du gouvernement interrogé le
gouvernement sur les droits aux
prestations sociales
et en particulier aux adresses à des
individus ayant soir enjoint des zones
de guerre soient ceux soutenant des
thèses qui en font des ennemis de la
france devenant quelques fractions le
sujet le gouvernement réprime toute
personne partant en syrie en irak bodiot
ailleurs pour rejoindre nos ennemis
l'action sur ce sujet et collectives et
elle associe l'ensemble des
administrations concernées ainsi dès
qu'un individu est convaincu d'être en
lien avec une entreprise terroriste
qu'ils soient soient condamnés en france
ou expulsés à ce titre il perd ses
droits aux prestations sociales de droit
commun dès que nous savons qu'un
individu a quitté le territoire national
pour rejoindre une zone de guerre nous
suspendons ses droits à prestations
sociales enfin en ce qui concerne les
prestations sociales et le rsa tout
signalement de départ par les autorités
compétentes donnent lieu à un réexamen
des droits se sont ouverts dans les
caisses nous pratiquons aussi déçu
invention de droit rsa aide au logement
prestations familiales assurance maladie
dès que nous savons que la personne ne
réside plus sur le territoire national
plusieurs centaines de dossiers ont été
examinés et ont donné lieu à des
suspensions de droits par ailleurs bien
sûr toutes les personnes qui sont
incarcérés parce qu'elles ont commis des
crimes et notamment le fait de
participer à des actions de guerre ne
peuvent prétendre aux prestations
sociales de droit commun de même les
individus qui sont expulsés vous en
parliez perdre leurs droits à
prestations sociales vous le voyez
monsieur le député notre action est
déterminé dans le respect du droit et je
ne voudrais pas que votre interrogation
légitime conduisent certains à faire des
amalgames nauséabonds
[Applaudissements]
à